okay hey what is up guys I'm Kay Bhd
here and this is not the first iPhone 5s
review and it probably won't be the last
but sometimes when you use the device
for a while longer than the typical
review period for tech reviewers you get
a little bit of a better sense of what
you like the device for and what you
don't like it for and just a little
tidbits and quirks about it and overall
a general idea of how well you like to
use it and that's exactly what this
video is about this is an iPhone 5s
review from the perspective of a person
who uses a lot of Google services I've
done videos about iOS before this is my
first iPhone review believe it or not
this took me like seven iPhones to
actually do a review of it but without
any further ado let's get right on into
this so this is the iPhone 5s in Space
Gray it comes in three colors but this
is the one I personally thought was my
favorite it's just as familiar as the
rest of the iPhones out there it's
running iOS 7 it has that familiar array
of icons like every other iPhone and
it's just as small in fact let me start
by saying that yes I'm aware that the
iPhone looks very small in my hands
that's because it is small in my hands
the Samsung Galaxy Note 3 is a phone
I've carried for a while now and it
feels pretty natural for me to hold but
it's a bigger than average phone for
most people and it has a 5.7 inch
display but to me it doesn't feel all
that extreme but a smaller more common
option that you'll probably see more
frequently is the samsung galaxy s4 this
is a pretty popular phone and it has a
5-inch display and has that same general
look to it as a Galaxy Note 3 but it
takes up less space and involves
reaching to the corners of it less but
even smaller than that is the Moto X
this is one of my favorite devices right
now and it's very compact it stuffs a
4.7 inch display into a body that's not
that much bigger than the iPhone so I
can grip the whole thing but even this
phone starts to look big when you
compare it to the iPhone 5s this phone
has a 4-inch display so it's easily the
smallest of the displays on any flagship
by any company right now but it's also
one of the most compact mobile devices
period which is something that Apple's
really
proud of in this phone and I don't blame
them the device is really light really
easy to hold and people can reach all
four corners of the display with one
hand although I think people could do
that on a four and a half inch display
too but this is also one of the most
fragile feeling phones out there it's
not actually fragile it's really
extremely well built it's made out of
premium materials like the HTC one it's
got metal in there it's very tightly put
together there's no creaking or any
twisting or anything like that but the
lack of any curves plus the glass on the
back like the Nexus 4 make it feel like
I better not drop this device like if I
drop it from a few inches up it feels
like it's very delicate and vulnerable
to scratches like I should be putting a
case on it or something now there are a
couple of things about the battery in
this device it's like we said a 1570
milliamp hour battery and that
measurement is pretty small in fact this
entire iPhone is about the same size as
a galaxy note 3 battery which is over
3000 milliamp hours so with this having
half the battery sizes and Note 3 has
its pros and has its cons one of the
important pros is that it charges very
quickly I'd like to say it charges
lightning fast but the cons are
immediately that the battery doesn't
last quite as long as any other
smartphone out there with a larger
battery now standby times are excellent
on the iPhone I could go to sleep with
an iPhone at 100% battery not charge it
and it would wake up with 97% battery
that's pretty good an Android device
with a similar sized battery might be at
80% when you wake up so that's pretty
good that iOS takes good advantage of
what it thinks you should be closing in
the background when you're sleeping but
it doesn't have the best battery life
during actual use in fact it's not even
quite as good as the iPhone 5 I'd say
maybe 5 percent worse than the iPhone 5
but it's it's about the same battery
life as you'd expect from an iPhone so
if you're coming from a previous
generation iPhone you won't find too
many surprises here with the battery
life everything else about the hardware
though is very well crafted we saw this
in the iPhone 5 - it's solid aluminum on
the sides in the back it has awesome
buttons that are precisely crafted so
that they don't wobble at all which is
nice plus they have the laser etchings
to indicate volume up and down the
chamfered edges are angled ever so
slightly inwards the headphone jack and
the Lightning port are on the bottom
with the precisely milled speaker grille
holes I mean I don't think it's it's
it's just about how all this is in such
a small package that makes it a little
difficult to appreciate
which is why I think HTC one still feels
just as good in the hand
now the speakers on the bottom of the
iPhone are one of the more interesting
parts of it I expected them to be really
good but check this out there are two
speaker grilles at the bottom of the
iPhone that looks great looks like
stereo speakers but it's actually just a
single driver on the right-hand side
sort of echoes over to the left-hand
side so if you cover up the left-hand
side
you will hear no change in the sound if
you cover up the right-hand side where
the driver is you can completely mute
the speakers so you have to be sure not
to do that by accident I'll give you a
sample of a sound completely muted well
anyway like we've said the iPhone has
obviously familiar Hardware on the
outside but what about the inside
because that's where the main change
came from between the 5 and the 5s now
if you thought the Moto X was a
consumer-oriented device that didn't
care about specs and targeted the
average consumer wait till you see the
spec sheet of the iPhone 5s it has on
paper the same specs as literally not
even exaggerating a flagship from 2011
meet the Samsung Galaxy s2 release date
April 2011 inside it had a dual-core 1.2
gigahertz chip 1 gigabyte of RAM 32
gigabytes of storage an 8 megapixel
camera and a 1650 milliamp hour battery
now meet the iPhone 5s release date a
couple weeks ago it has a dual-core 1.3
gigahertz chip 1 gigabyte of RAM 32
gigabytes of storage and 8 megapixel
camera and a 1570 milliamp hour battery
so this is where Apple does its absolute
best to make sure specs don't matter
nearly as much as I used to
they control the entire experience from
the hardware to the software and there's
a lot of optimization going on and in
the end performance throughout iOS 7 is
pretty snappy it performs on par with
just about every other flagship today
that has an 8 core chip and double the
RAM and 20 megapixel cameras and iOS as
we know never really required all that
much resources to run smoothly and
multitask well and not eat through
battery life like a hungry wolf through
steak so it's not really surprised that
the iPhone 5s is quite fast especially
when compared to older iPhones but how
is IO s7 well for me actually
like the look of ios7 at least a lot of
it but its functionality is still
exactly the same as iOS 6 it's
essentially a layer of gloss over the
top a visual overhaul if you will the
motto here is you'll probably like it or
learn to like it but if you don't too
bad because you just can't change things
you still can't customize a lot of the
things that I'm used to being able to
customize out-of-the-box on something
like an Android phone in iOS 7 you'll
probably like most of the new icons but
if you don't like one or two or several
too bad you might like the new keyboard
but if you don't too bad you might love
the new stock lockscreen or the new
dialer or all the new stock applications
but if you don't too bad my biggest
gripe with iOS 7 was actually the
animation so every time I unlock the
iPhone 5s there was this new animation
in iOS 7 that takes a solid half a
second before it lets me do anything on
the home screen and I don't like that at
all and that's too bad
so now anytime I want to unlock the
phone and I already know I want to go to
the second page of apps I have to wait
for the animation to finish before I can
do anything because wall is animating
its unresponsive on the touchscreen
still bugs me to this day I wish I could
change the animation speed just speed it
up a little bit there's also a lot of
weird little bits of fragmentation like
with the keyboard for example where if
the app you're using isn't updated for
iOS 7 it doesn't get to use Apple's new
keyboard goodies the old iOS 7 looking
keyboard which creates a bit of visual
inconsistency and that will I guess be a
bit of a mess until app developers get
on the case and update their apps for
the new OS but overall yeah I like the
look of a lot of iOS 7 I think it's
quite nice in a lot of areas that aren't
the icons on the home screen but the
functionality I still have problems with
and those still remain and that's too
bad now outside of this of course iOS is
still a great choice for a lot of people
and that obviously won't change I mean
10 million people bought this phone the
first weekend it was available so it's
clear that people love it and want it as
a Google service user with stuff you
know like Gmail Google Drive Google
Calendar tasks etc you can get most of
the core stuff you need and get away
with it from the app store so the
situation is really not that bad at all
and then there are of course the few
fringe benefits of the iPhone like touch
ID for example which is the name for the
fancy fingerprint sensor in the home
button of the iPhone lets you unlock
your phone or
vente Kate your iTunes purchases and you
can register up to ten fingers of course
people have also found great ways to
register things other than fingers like
their toes their pets toes and even
other body parts but uh it's a cool
feature it works pretty well pretty
accurately most of the time just note
that every time you restart your phone
you'll have to re-enter your whole
iTunes password before using touch ID
and app store again another thing that's
great about the iPhone is the camera
experience the camera experience in my
opinion is made up of two different
parts it's the quality and the control
and there's a little bit of the scale
I'd say between one and ten for quality
and between one and ten for control a
lot of devices that have ten out of ten
for quality like the Lumia 1020 for
example you can't just give it to a
random person on the street and ask them
to take a great photo with it they'll
probably have a little bit of difficulty
but if you get a really really easy to
use camera chances are it's not going to
take great photos so the iPhone strikes
a nice balance because on the scale of
one to ten for quality it's around an
eight and on the scale of one to ten for
control it's pretty simple but it's an
easy to use app so that's another eight
out of ten and I think that is what
makes it a very likable camera you can
just open it with a swipe up from the
shortcut in the corner and immediately
begin to take pictures so characterize
the camera on the back of the iPhone 5s
as a very fast camera and a bunch of
different ways fast number one because
it's very fast to take photos and to
process shots that's number two because
taking HDR's is very quick so you don't
have to have it necessarily still
subject fast number three because the
aperture itself is very fast is wide
open I believe it's F 2.0 or 2.2 which
can be a little bit softer than the
iPhone five but still is plenty fast and
great for low-light and again fast
because of the video modes in here you
can take really really fast 120 frames
per second video and then slow it down
to 30 frames per second to get this
awesome smooth slow-motion effect so
this is a very fast camera what I most
enjoyed about shooting with the 5s is
camera though was the low-light
capabilities the thing can essentially
see in the dark where a lot of the other
camera phones I've used fall short but
you can see all the test shots that I
took in the full imager link in the
description right below that like button
where I'll you see you know low-light
shots and regular light shots and
usually get the photos it takes are
really pretty solid the colors were very
accurate like extremely colorful and
created the detail was pretty much all
there it was only a little bit softer
than the iPhone 5 because of the wider
aperture but overall the shots you get
out of this thing are very good overall
though in terms of the quality of photos
and videos you get and the control you
have over them this is up there in some
of the best smartphones you can get to
take photos with so yeah using the
iPhone 5s is just as you would expect
you get great performance smooth
animations throughout you get that super
compact form factor and excellent build
quality and design and material choices
and you get the usual quirks with a
relatively new operating system but
those will either iron out or we will
get used to them you get that
future-proof ness with the new 64-bit
architecture apple's new chip and apple
having control over the whole OS and
ecosystem and have a very reliable
device that almost always works exactly
as you'd expect it to even if you don't
like the way it does something you can
be confident that it'll do it that way
every single time until you get used to
it it's a very familiar device for a lot
of people and probably isn't worth
rushing to upgrade to if you're coming
from an iPhone 5 but from any other
older iPhone it's a great choice for all
it's worth so at the end of the day
there are some things that are really
liked about the iPhone and some things
that I really don't like obviously about
the iPhone that a lot of other people
will probably agree with the display is
one of the most polarizing things to me
I love the quality of the display I just
wish it was bigger and there are a lot
of things that I like about the build
it's a beautifully crafted device it's
just a little bit too small and feels a
little bit fragile even though is in
fact really sturdy no creaking or
bending at all so there are some
polarizing things about it at the end of
the day though I'm not a big is user if
you want to see a full dedicated iOS
review or sort of a video on just me and
iOS who free to leave a comment below or
a thumbs up if you want to see something
like that but either way this has been
it this is the iPhone 5s in space grey
thank you for watching the review and
I'll talk to you guys in the next video
you